and our teacher go and let us put crazy
answers you just think of a funny thing
and then slowly see how it can Ling back
to the topic you're on creativity is
something that they want as part of
their lives that it's a way of looking
at the
[Music]
world
quantity over quality I think so we
don't uh h on my One Singular idea go
beyond the comfort zone you feel early
you succeed sooner so that was the thing
that we trying to drive across all the
team I don't think that it's fair to say
that we failed we just didn't succeed
there's a difference there there there's
a difference
there brought in a lot of industrial
examples which were very very precious
to uh the students they have shown what
actually happening around the world
outside the classroom Happ our challenge
statement allows us to look into the
real world problem that we are currently
facing and to think of solutions to
solve that problem in a real world
context very very
[Music]
welc we had to allow the student in
space to explore to give them room to
make error that's how we bu them run our
schools in a more empathetic way so that
we bring solutions to the real world
that making sense to everyone around
us so I think that the students will
have had a taste of it and they will
have enjoyed it I enjoyed the part where
I had to do first and laor programs like
this has allowed students to be given
the platform to exercise de creative
muscles and to see how creativity itself
can be uh enhanced when they work with
the Pierce so this something that I
thought this competition kind of allow
them to bu this into their
DNA I think there's no right or wrong
answer there's nothing wrong in having
your own
opinion I think this experience will
give me a chance to think whether I
should adjust my role that my daughter
has more control what she want to
[Music]
do